[Musique]
combien y at il des espèces de phoques
dans les autres c'est laurent quatre
espèces fréquentent les eaux du golfe et
de l'estuaire mais seulement 2 et
résident à l'année le phoque comme eux
est le plus petit des quatre espèces il
passe toute l'année dans cette grande
région et s'éloigne rarement des côtes
d'ailleurs on peut souvent l'apercevoir
en train de se prélasser au soleil sur
un rocher la population de phoques comme
eux compterait entre 20000 et 30000
individus le phoque gris réside aussi en
permanence dans les eaux du
saint-laurent c'est l'un des deux plus
gros phoque a fréquenté la région les
adultes peuvent atteindre le poids
impressionnant de 350 kg on dit du
phoque gris qu'il est le champion de
l'apnée il plonge à 300 mètres de
profondeur et pu rester trente minutes
sous l'eau on estime à plus de 500 mille
le nombre de phoques gris dans la région
du canada atlantique
le phoque du groenland est le plus connu
de toutes les espèces mais il nie que
visiteur hivernale la chasse
traditionnelle pratiquée sur la banquise
à terre-neuve et aux îles de la
madeleine a contribué à le faire
connaître
ce phoque mais bas sur les glaces au
printemps et remonte ensuite vers les
eaux arctiques pour y passer l'été la
population de phoques du groenland dans
l'atlantique nord ouest est estimée à
plus de 7 millions d'individus
l'autre visiteurs hivernale et le phoque
à capuchon
on reconnaît facilement les mâles à
leurs sacs gonflables qu'il porte sur le
museau leur population atteindrait près
de 600 mille individus dans la grande
région de l'atlantique nord ouest enfin
deux autres espèces visite parfois le
saint laurent le phoque annelé et le
phoque barbu peuvent être aperçus sur la
basse côte nord mais ces deux espèces
vivent surtout en arctique et leur
présence au sud est plutôt rare